[Music]
baby Yoho news yo-oh yo-oh army
submitted by carlos not an execute baby
oh look I'm Mexican actually busy and
now removing the wench auction from its
Pirates of the Caribbean oh oh that girl
was so hot for this auction when you
know the ride you know the ride right
yeah you know the scene where there's
like buy a bride yeah yeah oh no the
winches oh you know what's sad what I'm
not even mad about that what I'm mad
about is they changed a Treasure Island
theme and they made it that [ __ ]
Pirates of the Caribbean [ __ ] yeah I
like that
why oh and it at the very end it's Jack
Sparrow what's up [ __ ] man I mean he's
throughout the whole ride oh yeah hiding
in different places right drinkin and
music over here the Indiana Jones is
pretty cool it is dope I love that well
one time what's his name that gotta
plays Jack Sparrow dad that Johnny Depp
he [ __ ] trolled everybody by playing
Jack Sparrow in the Pirates right that's
my favorite ride though never ride soon
when he got the role he was like oh man
yep but I'm sad that they changed that
[ __ ] because they need to bring it back
to the old school yeah so after 50 years
is having the wench auction in the ride
they have now decided Disney has not
decided to change that scene in three
other parks so it's going to be the one
in Anaheim the one in Paris and one in
Orlando why so they're going to change
it to just an auction just [ __ ] whack
so it's an auction and sell your loot
and the red has still gonna be there cuz
she's a favorite yeah she's hot she's
the best one she's gonna be holding
stuff and then there's going to be a
line of men and women that are holding
their junk that are going to be a plow
works for me [ __ ] it they already [ __ ]
it all up off anyway
yeah they [ __ ] it up with a Jax well
that's more offensive than that [ __ ] so
letting get an article for that you know
what's offensive for people that love
dogs
that [ __ ] doggy with a key in his
mouth for me it's not that was my
favorite part the [ __ ] guys trying to
lure the doggy they shouldn't use dogs
for entertainment like that I was saying
that's my favorite part because the dogs
loyal to its master and he's like ha ha
ha ha ha you're a bad guy you think dogs
for entertainment that shit's wrong and
not real dog I still don't like it it's
a bad
they also have a parrot in there you oh
my god don't tell them about the pet
birds
what's wrong with the wench scene so
they're just saying that this bride
needs like an upgrade time and it's just
kind of the ride is not of the times it
is now reporting sorry period peepee at
the pier apiece half of this the
reaction is good it's about time we get
an upgrade whatever the other half which
is seems like it's the majority they're
saying like you know this this sucks I'm
going to agree one comment it says as
one of the less rides Walt Disney
oversaw I'm very sad they felt the need
to change this we need to stop shielding
people from history why don't we just
give all the Pirates cell phones instead
of interacting with each other yeah I
bet you they're going to take away that
guy chasing the girls around too well
there's one where the girl stays inside
because she's fat so see now they're
body shaming everything is going to be
oh no see that's the fat girl chasing
that guy because she's fat she doesn't
get no dick and then all these other
ones are like all the raping women maybe
it's just because like I think like as a
kid my mom taught me not to care about
stupid [ __ ]
like it's kind of like this it's like
how much does it affect your life and so
it's coming to the point now where I
maybe I'm exaggerating a little bit and
it could be a little bit of my cynicism
but if there is a small group that's
offended that's what the majority should
follow up now it's like I feel like
that's very offensive one like you know
of like a few select people so now we
all have to back that person like either
way you're going to find something every
day in the rest of your life that's
going to offend you it's not going to
change once you fix one thing something
else is going to offend you I actually
think that Walt Disney should have made
the pirate [ __ ] real because when I was
a little kid and I rolled that ride it
was scary well I was afraid of pirates
and I wanted to be
but then imagine if if like we're making
it so sugar-coated right if that was
already scary but I wanted to be one now
it's so sugar-coated that kids are going
to believe like Oh pirates are cool
people hysterically learn you should
have pirates shopping [ __ ] heads and
like really waiting people and follow
[ __ ] then kids will be like this is what
piracy was when the Pirates come to town
be careful yeah I went back on you're
saying about everyone getting offended
over everything like I could see this
the supporters of this because they're
they're saying like well might I bring
my kid here my kids getting influenced
and everything around but it's like your
job as a parent let them know too though
but that's my lazy parent back in a day
when Pirates took over towns they
rounded up all the ladies and they sold
them to be brides ooh scary yeah and
it'd be a pie out of like the like when
Django Unchained came out right yeah
that was a period piece about slavery
and they were using the n-word profusely
people got up from the theaters and they
walked out they're like how dare he put
that word in there so that [ __ ]
period piece too [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] if I
see a Western and there's a bunch of
Chinese people with bad English and
they're working on a realm I dude that's
historical I get it I'm watching it
right like it doesn't make sense yeah it
doesn't it just I don't know like I I
think that uh everything is it's a big
deal everything is becoming a big deal
now and maybe it's just my part like I
just don't give a [ __ ] enough to care
but this stuff has been around since I
was a kid I haven't really affected me I
kind of see the parents position now
because I think if I was you know
another day in time when I was a child
and I look at that [ __ ] and I go hole
pirates are cool they're selling women I
wanted to be a pirate and I would have
ended up being a pip because I wanted to
sell women just like Pirates do you
wouldn't did you have good parents that
are explaining it here yeah I just I was
in a [ __ ] idiot that's the thing I I
saw that [ __ ] at six years old and I was
like wow this is scary they're selling
their selling Brides away I wouldn't
want to be the bride being sold I think
we also like if it's like with children
to like from what I'm seeing like
trending
online and stuff is that we have a
tendency now or people who don't have
kids right they have a tendency to say
I'm trying to protect my future kids
from stuff when really in my personal
opinion is you shouldn't be trying to
protect your kids you should be trying
to give them values to strengthen as
human beings to able to fight everyday
life things because I don't want my kid
to always see something get pissed off
are upset about every little thing and
then become a [ __ ] in the sense that
you wind every day about stuff that it
affects you emotionally you could want
to complain a joke around but it's
affection was a human being where you
can't function because of all these
external stuff I don't want that [ __ ]
you know what they should be complaining
about it's the high [ __ ] prices at
Disneyland
yes what's the accessible these are
[ __ ] problem you know what's a bigger
problem than [ __ ] winches very
expensive no does he's making money from
your kids cuz I'm using that Arjun I
also think it's a big problem too they
don't have enough churro
stands and pretzel stands because by the
time I buy a churro
as I'm walking to the next Charlestown
already burned off that Journal and I
need to have another trail in the middle
you know I don't want to have to burn
off all those turtles as I'm going from
one skanky there honestly one thing that
you've eaten at Disneyland that you
would eat outside and say this is
[ __ ] below the cream cheese filling
pickled vegetable but also when you're
in the land of magic I eat the horn I
eat the churro the turkey leg to tell
with the Dole Whip there's that fried
chicken place from the pink and white
place what is up its called I know she
come up there's that place mm-hmm and
then the [ __ ] frozen lemonade [ __ ]
and then you're like a hundred dollars
in the bag right yeah I am my inner
child is not iris be right there the
whole pirate ride should be [ __ ]
Disneyland you just go on that thing and
it's like Walt Disney cracking up and
it's people paying all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] turkey leg and [ __ ]
$20 Tucker leg and it's dry as [ __ ] -
right well I was [ __ ] upset when I
first had that circulate if that [ __ ] is
dry and don't be funky as a [ __ ]
[ __ ] is that [ __ ] that's literally a
four pound piece of [ __ ] beef jerky
yeah
it's [ __ ] I was so upset because
everytime people eat that [ __ ] on the
Instagram they're like oh yeah like well
they hit that [ __ ] they seem like they
do it like they've never seen food
before in their life and so I got hype
right I'm not I'm not a native from
NorCal son so I went there I grabbed it
Isaac correct throw it away
wait wait but what about your turkey
legs I like festivals
well sacrum exact so Sacramento where we
have our State Fair that turkey legs
bomb could've gone [ __ ] that just
[ __ ] salty and right now I haven't
been a Disneyland in a minute oh yeah
before they [ __ ] change this [ __ ]
sack of [ __ ] I need to like remember
are you [ __ ] like ingrain it in my
eyes before this pirate ride so the
pirate goes away the pirate ride goes
away laughs I love to put dude I'm
saying that they're gonna start some
changes first in Paris this month yeah
change over there first
yeah and then next year they're going to
change in Mercer no enough Anna next
they're gonna take away the guns from
the buzz lightyear what ride because you
can't they don't want kids Ashu [ __ ]
take a little cannon oh yeah no the buzz
are you good yeah yeah actually only
seen the first one never seen anyone
after that oh we already had this
conversation
don't offend me but why does that offend
you [ __ ] because you didn't even give n
love Toy Story and you were like math
right
okay you see that's not saying don't
going on a toy story like as a good as a
story like it's really good it is really
good you piece of [ __ ] everybody loves
it I think its kind ever sales bad iw
baby I don't love it like everybody else
and that's what the [ __ ] this Emile I
don't want a conversation you don't know
you don't know the literally genius that
they had put in there you know it's a
literary genius I think there's a lot
other animated films like you know [ __ ]
is like what you want like which one
which I mean from your girdle
oh yeah that's a movie you're not better
than Toy Story are you kidding me what I
saw in the classic when it again Toy
Story is like The Sopranos it was like
the precursor and the innovator of a lot
of animation Sigma lecture
yeah did you wash it when I first came
out leader I watched it when it first
came out and I also watched it oh my god
oh he's I watched it later so that's why
it was it like wow we mean what could I
marry what no because I'll wash it later
so I already saw a bunch of other stuff
no because that means your eyes are a
very unbiased opinion and so for me I'm
saying it's good I'm not but everybody
says like oh boy story you're not my
mother
it was pretty awesome school I think
it's how washing up on the first came
out at that time my eyes haven't been
game bein about all the new [ __ ] I would
think I want to loved it what's this you
know main story noise are you kidding
only one or all of them I watched the
first one and I might have seen the
second one but that just goes to show
that the second one wasn't memorable
enough for me to remember first and the
third one's the benefit is pretty much
like if I watched if I want to order
that if I sort of rings out because it's
artic my eyes we've been game being by
Game of Thrones I might not like Lord of
the Rings as much and people who watch
the Lord of the Rings for the first time
without without having been gaming by a
game of Thrones Oliver so I mean it's
not discovery I will say this though Toy
Story is like one of those films -
despite the fact that the animation
obviously isn't up to par without now it
still stands the test of time there's a
lot of films I've seen since on the kid
that I've watched now as a piece of [ __ ]
like right yeah
Karate Kid I love that one have you seen
recently I have the [ __ ] DVD triple
set go go watch it go watch it tonight
and then watch some [ __ ] funny [ __ ]
cuz you'll crack up throughout that
whole painting okay it's bad but it's
nostalgic well that's what I'm saying
it's like bloodsport you know know know
what a head of it don't think about it
it's the most multicultural film I said
when it came out
yomo I saw it will fill today I said
five years you know a tanaka show us the
death touch what's a death touch the Big
Mac I thought they meant death touch no
wonder you guys don't like toys are you
okay did your [ __ ] childhood um
except is my childhood Oh came out when
we were older okay you would a okay USA
do
and also another some of those then
there's a time judge dredd [ __ ]
terrible movie
it was terrible when he came out the
[ __ ] are you talking about yeah there
you go that was a horrible movie agent
Hershey yeah hey you guys want to stock
any of us we'll go ahead down to the
description box below and you can follow
us on Instagram and all kinds of stuff
for more videos
[Music]